now a russian figure skater uh camilla
camila valeva will be allowed to compete
at the beijing olympics following a
decision by the court of arbitration for
sport the 15 year old helped the
russians win the team event last week
but then reports of a positive doping
test for a heart medication from
december emerged
the court ruled that valeeva should not
be provisionally suspended ahead of a
full hearing into the case she's favored
to win gold at the women's individual
event which takes place tomorrow
let's get more from dw sports
correspondent jonathan crane who's in
beijing welcome jonathan so just first
of all explain the court's ruling to us
well essentially the court had to
balance two things one is the integrity
of competition if it turns out valia is
guilty of doping how would it damage
that integrity but the other thing
that's had to weigh up is the fairness
on valeeva she is 15 years old as such
she's a protected person under
anti-doping rules and that means that
she is entitled to less harsher um
punishments and essentially the court
said look if valeeva wasn't allowed to
compete and it turns out later that she
isn't guilty of doping then that would
cause her personally significant harm
now
the court also said it was unacceptable
that it took six weeks for this positive
doping test to come to light that
clearly is not valeeva's fault it's not
her fault that this has overshadowed her
olympic games now we had a press
conference uh today from the court of
arbitration for sport there were no
questions but this is what the general
secretary matia reb said in a statement
the panel considered fundamental
principles of fairness
irreparable harm and the relative
balance of interest as between the
applicants and the athlete who did not
test positive
during the olympic games in beijing
but is still subject to a disciplinary
procedure on the merits following her
positive anti-doping test
undergone in december 2021 in particular
the panel considered that preventing the
athlete to compete at the olympic games
would cause her irreparable harm
in these circumstances
so jonathan crane this is not uh done
and dusted there are still lots of
uncertainties
yeah indeed while we're going to see
valeeva compete now and there's no
doubting she's an incredible talent she
was the first woman to land a quadruple
jumping competition not just once but
twice
the court hasn't ruled whether she is
guilty of doping or not that will
probably come at a later stage because
valeeva is entitled to have her b sample
tested that is effectively a backup
sample that would confirm whether the
first test was indeed positive now the
ioc wanted everything done and dusted
now they wanted that to be heard as well
but uh one of the parties didn't agree
we can only assume that was the russian
side so it may well be that valeava
comes away from beijing with two gold
medals to her name she is the heavy
favorite to win gold in the individual
event and yet be stripped of those gold
medals at a later date
and as you mentioned um uh camilla
valeeva is only 15 so what does this
controversy tell us about the adults
advising her
yes of course i mean we said again we
mustn't forget that she is 15 years old
so
even if she did dope there are question
marks about whether she would be solely
responsible for that clearly she puts a
lot of trust in the people around her be
it her coaches team advisors doctors now
wada the world anti-doping agency has
said it will investigate her entourage
there are kind of echoes here aren't
there of of east germany and the doping
regime there where young athletes were
given banned substances dressed up as
vitamins now whatever happens again
russian doping has come into the
spotlight the whole reason one of the
reasons russia's ban was cut was to
protect a younger generation of athletes
and allow them to compete so there is a
certain irony in the fact that it is a
young athlete now at the center of
another doping controversy it's a very
messy situation all round
thank that jonathan jonathan crane in
beijing